c'était en mars les États-Unis et le
Canada rendaient leurs frontières encore
plus étanche pour freiner les migrations
irrégulières notre choix a été de
moderniser l'entente sur les tiers pays
sûr après la fermeture du chemin Roxane
les organismes qui défendent les droits
des réfugiés subissent un autre coup dur
la décision d'aujourd'hui ne change pas
les dangers auxquels les réfugiés font
face la Cour suprême a tranchée
constitutionnelle cet accord permet au
Canada de refouler les demandeurs
d'asile en provenance des États-Unis
puisque ce pays est considéré sur une
atteinte à la liberté et à la sécurité
de la personne ont fait valoir les
groupes de défense des réfugiés devant
le tribunal nous demandons au
gouvernement de se retirer de l'Entente
le plus tôt possible
qui sont retournés aux États-Unis sont
plus à risque d'être détenus et renvoyés
dans leur pays d'origine mais le risque
de détention auquel sont exposées des
personnes leur retour aux États-Unis n'a
pas une portée excessive tranche la Cour
suprême dans une décision unanime le
ministre fédéral de l'immigration se
réjouit et défend le système
d'immigration américaine le système dans
les États-Unis ça marche dans son
jugement la Cour souligne que des
exemptions existent dans la loi
canadienne pour protéger les demandeurs
dont les droits sont menacés oui sur
papier mais pas en pratique font valoir
les appeler les gens aux frontières
n'ont pas les outils pour les utiliser
selon le NPD les femmes sont plus à
risque de subir un préjudice si elles
sont renvoyées aux États-Unis ils
craquent les victimes de persécution
fondées sur le genre et de violences
sexuelles se voient refuser l'asile aux
États-Unis
disent les conservateurs
Ottawa doit avant tout remettre de
l'ordre dans son système d'immigration
et s'attaquer au long des lettres de
traitement par trouver une stabilité
dans notre gestion de nos dossiers
d'immigration nous assurer qu'il y ait
de la quête de la rigueur le dossier
n'est pas entièrement clos la Cour
suprême a demandé un tribunal inférieur
d'évaluer si l'entente contrevient à
l'article 15 de la Charte des droits et
libertés ainsi la Cour fédérale devra
déterminer si l'accord porte préjudice
aux femmes qui craignent d'être
persécutés en raison de leur genre ici
Louis Blouin Radio-Canada Ottawa